künstliche Intelligenz wird in mühsamer
Forschungsarbeit der Natur nachempfunden
denn Gehirne sind lernfähiger und
effizienter als KI aber die Firma
cortical Labs in Australien will sich
den Aufwand einfach sparen sie bauen
echte Neuronen in Computer ein das
dishbrain besteht aus einem Netzwerk von
Neuronen auf einer Platine voller
elektrischer Kontakte diese dienen als
Interface mit dem Computer in einer
ersten Studie hat dishbrain nach wenigen
spielwiederholungen begonnen eine
vereinfachte Version des Spiels Pong zu
lernen menschliche Neuronen haben dabei
besser performt als die von
der Haken ein künstliches neuronales
Netzwerk braucht zwar mehr
spielwiederholungen spielt diese aber
viel schneller durch auf der anderen
Seite hat dishbrain auch nur wenige
hundert Neuronen während das menschliche
Gehirn etwa 86 Milliarden hat dishbrain
ließe sich also skalieren ob daraus
jemals eine brauchbare Technologie wird
das bleibt unklar und ein bisschen
gruselig ist die Vorstellung ja auch
schon denn